a Louisiana officer is speaking out
about the crash she blames on carbon
monoxide in her police Ford Explorer she
is suing the automaker Ford engineers
are in Austin repairing some of the 400
police vehicles taken out of service
over carbon monoxide concerns Ford
released new images showing one way the
gas may be getting in the company says
holes were created when police equipment
was put in after the SUVs were bought
now we followed this investigation for
six months it now covers more than 1.3
million Ford Explorers regulators say
they lack clear proof that carbon
monoxide is to blame Kris Van Cleave is
in Henderson Louisiana with new evidence
that appears to refute that Chris good
morning good morning you can see the
damage to this Ford Explorer it's a 2016
police interceptor the officer who was
driving said it only been on the road
about nine months before she says she
apparently blacked out behind the wheel
and crashed her department asked for a
special blood test and it showed carbon
monoxide no they just had in April
witnesses say this Henderson police Ford
Explorer slowly drifted off the road
before flipping onto its side Randy when
you look at your cruiser what's going
through your mind I don't know how I
live through that I shouldn't be
standing here today after officer brandi
sicky doesn't remember the crash but the
steering wheel is bent from where she
hit it and her hair is still in the
windshield I drove into town I drove
what had once four people and I got on
the highway and I remember any of that
no recollection ever one none the
National Highway Traffic Safety
Administration or Nitsa is investigating
thousands of reports of exhaust which
contains carbon monoxide seeping into
the cabins of police interceptors and
civilian explorers while Nitsa has
received reports of three crashes and 41
injuries investigators say so far
there's no actual evidence they were the
result of carbon monoxide poisoning but
medical records show doctors diagnosed
sickie with carbon monoxide poisoning
more than two hours after the crash her
blood still showed potentially dangerous
Co level
summer Brown is sickies attorney there
is no other source by which the carbon
monoxide got into my clients system
other than her vehicle and Nitsa is
aware of that the medical records sickie
shared also showed the presence of
medications that she says were
prescribed doctors we talked to say they
don't know if that could have
contributed to the crash Ford released
these images of what it says maybe
allowing carbon monoxide to get into
some police explorers unsealed holes
like this one by a vehicle's muffler or
here along the rear spoiler part of
after purchase work done by third-party
contractors to install emergency
equipment but that does not explain the
complaints of exhaustion civilian
explorers
what kind of patrol car do you drive now
2017 Ford Explorer sickie is now back on
the job and back behind the wheel of a
police cruiser does that make you
nervous yes there I have a carbon
monoxide detector also in it but every
hour I want to get out the vehicle walk
around and I think it's might be
impacting my work because I'm I never
had to do that before and I'm doing it
now Ford maintains that safety is its
top priority it is fixing police
explorers free of cost and maintains
that civilian explorers are safe to
drive Ford declined comment on this case
in particular because of the pending
litigation we asked Nitsa about those
injury reports the agency said they get
back to us Margaret that was Monday
Chris important reporting there and I
know you'll continue to follow it for us